[Música]
como anunciaba comenzamos con nuestra
sección directo a en France 24 hoy nos
vamos hasta Caracas la capital de
Venezuela para ampliar con nuestra
corresponsal Daniela Zambrano toda la
información relativa al primer vuelo de
la aerolínea Estatal colombiana satena
tras la reapertura de fronteras entre
ambas naciones vecinas hablaremos
también de la reunión que la oposición
venezolana y representantes del gobierno
tendrán en París en el marco del foro
por la paz Daniela Cómo ha sido ese
primer vuelo Bogotá Caracas y que se
espera de este inicio de operaciones
entre ambos países parece que el 28 de
noviembre comenzarán a llegar vuelos
desde Barranquilla
hasta el momento formalmente están
reanudadas las operaciones aéreas entre
Colombia y Venezuela pero solo
confirmados dos vuelos semanales que
Irán desde Bogotá hasta Caracas los días
miércoles y viernes por parte de la
aerolínea satina y dos vuelos desde
Caracas hasta Bogotá por parte de la
aerolínea turpial que serían los lunes y
sábados esto lo confirmó el ministro de
transporte Guillermo Reyes quien estuvo
en ese avión que llegó este miércoles al
Aeropuerto Internacional de maiquetía
con 45 pasajeros a bordos entre ellos
pero periodistas colombianos algunos
venezolanos que retornaban al país y el
ministro que se sostuvo una reunión en
el Aeropuerto Internacional de maiquetía
con su par venezolano Ramón Velázquez un
punto importante del que se habló
también es que el propio presidente
Gustavo Petro solicitó a Estados Unidos
según una reunión que tuvieron hace un
par de semanas con el subsecretario de
estado de Estados Unidos revisar la de
la aerolínea Estatal venezolana conviasa
recordemos Esto está sancionada por el
departamento del tesoro de Estados
Unidos y no tiene permitido o no ha
podido realizar los vuelos entre Bogotá
y Caracas y fue una de las razones por
las cuales se postergó tanto esta
conexión aérea que estaba prevista para
el pasado 26 de septiembre cuando se
reabrió la frontera entre ambos países
lo que dijo el ministro Es que este no
es un tema cerrado y que habían
solicitado formalmente a Estados Unidos
revisar esta situación no se descarta
que antes de finalizar el año otras
aerolíneas colombianas puedan también
viajar a Venezuela y en cuanto a la
política interna del país Daniela hemos
conocido que la oposición y
representantes del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro retomarán conversaciones en el
Foro de París por la paz este viernes
cómo se ha gestado esta retoma de
diálogos y que espera la oposición sacar
de ellos
esto ha sido gracias a la mediación del
presidente de Francia Emmanuel macron
entre otras razones como lo decía es la
reunión será este viernes 11 de
noviembre va a ser una reunión privada
por parte de la oposición venezolana
estará el jefe de la negociación Gerardo
Blade y por parte del gobierno también
presidente de la asamblea nacional Jorge
Rodríguez el principal tema es tratar de
abordar una solución a la crisis social
que atraviesa Venezuela y por parte de
la oposición también Buscar condiciones
para algunas elecciones presidenciales
libres y justas es lo que se está
discutiendo recordemos que estas
negociaciones iniciaron en agosto de
2021 en México sin embargo tres meses
después fueron suspendidas luego de que
Estados Unidos decidiera extraditar al
empresario colombiano alexad a Estados
Unidos y el gobierno de Nicolás maduro
lo tildara de secuestro y exigiera su
Liberación para poder reanudar este
diálogo con la oposición hay
expectativas sobre eh esta nueva reunión
pues eh desde hace algunos meses se
venía hablando y no se había
materializado